quiet demon this one's drawing the T
John Moran minutes uneasy labor KJ
Williams discrete and colors
switch off John on him so Moran takes it
and throws it Murray answers the triple
drum Marcus ended up at age basketball
diamond in the rods Murray State the
racers were red drawers the team slips
it into car 11 straight wins since
February 2nd for Murray State job around
lips to the corner eaves three by JAMA
ran giving him five rebounds now whip to
the head if you can and in top wants to
play and watch the ball
the tournament's two leading scorers and
[Applause]
what a great backdoor cut
oh boy at the rim Wow
guarding marques Howard it's over to the
wing to miss three another rebound Oh
ran back in striking distance
Marcus Howard floater in transition
Moran has another rebound and Chuck
you can and hammers at home joining job
tell you what Brendon Bailey's does get
a job as you really can't do it is so
impossible look at that fee
Marcus Howard 23 points out 27 field
goal attempts from moraine
Marcus Howard 23 points out 27 field
goal attempts
look from Moran